ils vivent et en dehors les chemins
forestiers
ce n'était nullement un arbre de métier
il n'avait jamais vu l'ombre d'un
bûcheron ce grand chêne pierre sueur
centre ont ils eu connu des jours fils
adorent et de soi sans ses proches
voisins les pires gens qui soient des
roseaux mal pensant pas même dépend peau
s'amusant talent le mettre à bout du
matin jusqu'au soir
ces petits rejetons tout juste canne à
pêche à peine mirliton lui tonnant tout
autour chantaient-ils et cinsault
l'histoire du chêne et du roseau et bien
qu'il fût en bois les chaînes c'est
court la fable ne le laissait pas
indifférent il advint que lassé d'être
en butte aulas dit il se résolut tu as
les yeux
à grand peine il sorti ses grands pieds
le sont on est parti sans se retourner
ni vu ni poux mais moi qu'il ait connu
je sais bien qu il souffrit de quitter
l'ingrate bataille à l'orée des forêts
le chêne ténébreux à lier connaissance
avec deux amoureux grand chêne res nous
sur toi grave et non le grand chêne n'a
pas dit non quand ils eurent épuisé
leurs grands sacs de baisser qu'en deux
temps s'embrasser le bec furent refusées
il où il est alors en retenant les
pleurs le chaîne comptant ses malheurs
branche elle vient chez nous tu trouvera
la paix
noro savent vivre et n'ont aucun tout
près tu feras dans nos murs
un aimable séjour à oser quatre fois par
jour
cela dit
tous les trois se mirent temps chemin
chaque amoureux tenants d'une racine en
main comme il semblait content comme il
semblait heureux
le chêne antho ces amoureux au pied de
leurs chaumières
ils le firent planté ce fut alors qu'il
commence à 2d chanter car en fait
d'arrosage il n'eut rien que la pluie
des chiens le vent la pâte sur lui
on a pris tous ses glands pour nourrir
les cochons avec sa belle corse
on a fait des bouchons chaque fois qu'un
arrêt de mort a été rendue c'est luc
héritait du pendu puis ces mauvaises
francs vandal a accompli le coup pertes
en quatre et s'enfuir d'un lit et l'
horrible mégère ayant d'états d'âme ans
il vieillit prématurément
un triste jour enfin ce couple sans aveu
le passa pas relâche et le mit dans le
feu comme du bois de caisse à mr
destinée il périt dans la cheminée
le curé le chez-nous petit saint besoin
dieu doute que sa fumée s'élève jusqu'à
dieu qu'est ce qu'il en sait le bougre
et qui donc lui at il ya pas de chaîne
en paradis n'ya pas de chaîne entrave à